when you decided to do american idol you
were working you had uh been on cruise
ships for disney was it the hercules
show i did hercules the musical where i
played california the head music and i
sang the circle of life soloists so it
was two shows like was it back two days
like tuesday and wednesday so your
career was one where things were
happening you were starting to make some
money because i mean disney was paying
you yes they were and that was legit
yeah that was legit disney
is real honey is that your first real
paycheck in the business actually no my
first real paycheck interview so before
then i worked at burger king right
that was my job and i used to sing in
the drive-through right did you really
sing in the driveway yeah i used to sing
it because it was a mic honey yeah so
that was my stage so let's say i pull up
i go uh i'd like to have uh two fries
i don't know what i would be singing but
you would hear my mouth just
singing away and they'll pull up and
they're like
you knew what car was coming because it
would be beep beep and my sister she was
like the queen of burger king and she
used to fuss at me do your job you know
you don't know what you're doing but i
just wanted to sing a song so i was
singing there and
somehow like the
head manager of burger king was a club
promoter too oh so he started to hire me
to sing at his
cubs
and i started making more money singing
one night at the club then i did for two
weeks at burger king burning my face on
the boiler and all of that stuff and i
was like how long were you at burger
king
peg that's a good question
was it months or years the first job the
first time i worked there i was 16.
right but then i quit right because it
was just not for me and then i
eventually went back and i think i was
there maybe
a year or two
it's hard work isn't it it is it is and
what did you make fries did you did you
do everything i
yeah the second time around the first
time i couldn't do nothing right right
but the second time yes i used to do all
the burgers and
the fries um but mainly work in a
drive-through and singing but isn't it
great that here you were a burger king
of course gave you an opportunity to
make a couple of bucks but isn't it
great that sort of you got discovered
and started working in clubs because the
guy at burger king recognized what a
lucky break
and isn't this a lesson in a sense that
wherever you are sing if you want to be
a singer and who knows and do your best
job even if you're a burger king and
maybe somebody will discover you yeah it
that's what i was thinking back then you
know because you don't even know who
might be driving through right you don't
know and even like i have people singing
to me today you know i'll be like oh
lord they thinking like i was thinking
back then
every time you went to the corner
oh my god i was just like that did they
do that to you do people come up and
sort of audition and say they'll just be
like wandering around whether close
enough so you hear them